what is up people we're gonna watch the
bad batch today
star wars show
[Laughter]
accurate descriptions you guys didn't
know this one's called devil's oh god
john make your dumb mephisto joke guys
marvel tie-in
we're gonna finally meet mephisto thanks
for watching you can hit that like
button if you enjoy our video and you
can subscribe and click that bell
full-length watch long is really single
with the top code over at our patreon
cover bunch of other shows over there as
well for those reaction highlights like
how you'll see in this video and full
length watch alongs at the same tier and
thank you to pratham jindal for editing
these highlights together for us
now let's watch mephisto join the star
wars cinematic universe
be happy i was so happy happy gosh
and then in real life he doesn't shut up
about it i see devil and i think of the
spooky elevator movie so you should
no you don't last time you're watching
devil you're like oh it's that mephisto
[Music]
the twilight zone i have a visual
i'm gonna be clean as fighters are here
look how
dirty his suit is to represent the filth
on his soul
i'm disappointed senator despite our new
refinery bringing
countless jobs to your citizens they
seem troubled by our presence
i speak for the people when i say this
partnership
is most welcome wouldn't you agree
cinderella i will always support
that which helps hiloth and what about
you
general do you share your wife's outlook
i don't think he does
after years spent fighting peace is what
is needed
and with peace comes prosperity this is
a new era for ryloth
twilight looks familiar i feel like he's
in a prequel or something
tell me our new refinery will bring
stability and growth
to ryloth once again now is the time
for all twilights to step down from
their military posts
we want to do that we want
war we want to work i understand your
uneasiness we would not be here today
if it wasn't for them they fought with
us
they fought for us the war
has ended let us lay down our weapons
and focus on ryloth's
future no that's how you give a speech a
rousing leader right there
except not to that bad batch what a
shame your daughter is not here to share
in this
hera has other interests
she's the mother of hera
who is he heroin anything suspicious yet
we're seeing hera in this dude hair is
gonna be here who's
you gotta enlighten me now
just a mining facility i overheard
father say this is only the first
location
no we can't go uncle goby told us to
stay and gather intel
i chose the right color today yeah
absolutely
there's a premonition harry is in uh the
main twilight
in rebels gotcha
who dreams of light like ray and luke
that sucks
chopper by turning over our weapons he's
made us defenseless
i've already reached out to my contact
to acquire more
oh boy sorry about this general but they
were found inside a restricted zone we
were just
exploring i won't report this but it
can't happen again
i assure you it won't what were you
doing out there
i want the truth hera i sent her
the imperial refinery is off limits hera
you know that uh i never said we were at
the refinery
i have my ways too tell me what you saw
leave nothing out do you realize what
could have happened if this was reported
my daughter spying on an imperial
facility why would it be spying
what don't they want us to see oh what
way to flip it great question the clones
were supposed to leave right lot when
the war ended
i will not stand by one more arrive each
day
i'm telling you the imperials are up to
something you just don't want to see it
can't you tell by how sinister they
behave
[Laughter]
did you see how the crowd reacted to him
his influence over them is a problem
go big please your real threat look at
this scar
yeah it was like a gaping hole
do you still dream of flying all the
time
then i can go far from here
my dream was for a free ride for our
people to happily live in a world of
peace
we have that now the people don't seem
very happy
their lives much like yours have been
surrounded by war for far too long
uncle gobi doesn't think so he and i
want the same things
but differ in our approach if we need to
fight i am as capable as anyone
gobby trusts me to do my part why
can't you fighting it takes a toll
my hope is that you won't ever have to
live a life like mine
well
listen
as you can see we are in the early
stages but the dunya mind here will
rebuild parts of the galaxy
affected by the war the devil's deal
this
finally would not be a military facility
but your soldiers and armaments suggest
otherwise
under the republic's rule your planet
was vulnerable but that is no longer the
case
the empire is dedicated to protecting
the interests of ryloth
more about his own interest than those
of our people
how can we trust these imperials when
they are keeping things from us
we need to try for the sake of ryloth
and if the empire's version of peace is
not one we can accept
then what well then your daughter's
gonna do some badass [ __ ] in the future
you're late let's get moving i can't go
i'm sorry all right but i was going to
let you fly this time
fly really i guess it would have to wait
chop cover for me wait
oh how cool oh no
so it's like the oh no oh no
kids always be running off
police ship's been tagged and he's not
alone
making our approach at 162
how was that yes yes very good now he's
off on the thrust
it's time to land i can do it no take
off the landings not yet
watch and learn the contact's inbound
wow can't even see like the origins of
her
piloting ships yay
skills under pressure what supplies are
we here to get
weapons but we just turned over all our
weapons to the empire
not for long
i've never seen a ship like that before
neat oh cool yeah
i forgot all about the bad [ __ ] i'm not
gonna lie
that's okay it's a sign of a compelling
decision everybody
recognize the [ __ ] for a second
it's all good that one was for me
[Laughter]
let's see them
what type of ship is this a modified
omicron class attack shuttle
can i have a look inside but no funny
business i'll be watching you
this is the sensor array and that's the
deflector shield over there's the nav
reader and this is the hyperdrive
you sure know a lot about this do you
fly tech won't let me train until i can
recite all of the ship's specifications
from memory
flying is it's about a feeling what do
you mean
when i close my eyes and picture myself
up there
i feel it the instruments help guide you
but you plot your course
you're free so you're a pilot
no not yet but one day
[Music]
i'll show you my favorite part of the
ship this is a toilet
[Laughter]
we didn't have this on kamino
it's my room who's chasing you
are you in some kind of trouble i
thought you were in trouble
isn't that why we're here it's a start i
have sid contact me when she has more to
sell
building an arsenal attracts attention
you better know what you're getting into
we don't have a choice this is so neat
thanks for the tour any time
for them to not talk
they're like instrumental in um the
revolution
yeah yeah and you're seeing they didn't
realize it the different ways in which
they're impacted
flying is about a feeling what feeling
[Laughter]
use the force luke now let's just hope
cross everyone
show up here it's bad wherever he is
wow mad max i was i was so
into this that uh this madman showed up
like oh damn i forgot we're watching a
bad bat show for a second
we've got an imperial ship approaching
try to lose them
you're such a dick cross hair
i wish that hole in your head could have
got the chip
[Music]
that's what's gonna kill you
these three were called smuggling
weapons onto the planet
i find your involvement in such matters
to be most distressing
jams behind this she's the proof he's
plotting and
uprising that's not true you being here
is enough to implicate him
cham has not committed a crime yet but
this syndulla has
so she's only a child she is an insult
take them away whoa they're protesting
against it yeah
i'm clocking three of glee's fighters on
the western ridge
should i take care of them no let them
report back
just make sure you get into position
[Music]
we have to contact the general
we must intercept that convoy before it
reaches the capital where are they now
western outskirts sector three japan
let's go
split up stay here and wait for my
signal
[Music]
[Music]
awesome awesome
awesome yes
more speeder bikes please it's indulge
i knew it what are you waiting for
attack
yes sir
[Music]
no crosshairs i'm so worried across
they're just gonna shoot one of them i
know
it's gonna come out of nowhere
where are the reinforcements
our calms have been cut what do we do
now
you must hold them off until
reinforcements get here tell them
we surrender surrender interest
mom what is father going to do
tao will not let this go let us worry
about that
how dare you attack our convoy you are
all traitors
you threaten my daughter and accuse her
of treason
for years i've watched you put your
greed and self-interests above ryloth
you are the one guilty of treason do
something
he's the one holding the blaster
oh no
but not this way that'll be due to
diabetes
oh no arrest these insurgents for the
attempted assassination of on free time
ah damn
[Music]
damn
[Music]
uh hurts the syndulla girl won't get far
have our forces find her
[Music]
don't do it oh i got
chills my nipples are piercing through
my shirt
good episode nice i think the uncle i'm
pretty sure he's like
uh maybe in rebels but i'm pretty sure
he's in like
early on clone wars episodes i'm not
sure it's sometimes a little confusing
for me with the twilights
right now it's okay you're doing a great
job
you're killing the game keeping up with
all the d the name matter
there's something about this he looks
very familiar
a little nervous but i'm pretty sure
like early on in clone wars he was
involved
for a little tiny bit here yeah
let's do this let's talk about it all
right yes goby glee
was uh in the clown yes he was part of
the twilight
resistance that opposed the separatists
a lot yes okay
okay i remember the reason okay it's
gonna sound like a stupid thought
because it doesn't
it doesn't look like this he doesn't i
didn't get the thought
here but for some reason in the clone
wars i would have the thought of that
guy kind of looks like james
woods if you want to i can see it
oh no i didn't have that thought here
but that was popping in my head i was
like
for some reason this is this is the
thought that's going through my brain
right now i like james woods yeah
um okay i i thought this was a really
good episode
i was really into it i for those couple
of my favorite episodes of this have
been the ones that actually feature the
bad batch the least it's not the
to say i i don't like the bad batch i
quite i quite do i'm very much
i'm excited when they show up but i like
the shift in perspective
and it was neat how they thrusted you in
here and i wasn't even
aware of like oh yeah where's the bad
i didn't even question where they were i
was uh
like this this had such good
conversation
about what's the this transitional
period
because it seemed like how do i put it
it seemed like back then
before the this galactic empire came to
be
in order 66 and all that that the
war was it was a rather black and white
situation
you know good versus evil and there
didn't seem to be much
gray to the objective here and
this seems to be exploring the gray in
ways that i wasn't even
quite sure how they would do it i'm
forgetting the names of everyone already
but the the dad the one who influences
the twilights
how he is just striving for you know
looking out for the planet
peace for everyone and
yet you know the uncle uh the james
woods
he can censor something different and
like like the line that was established
to hara
that they have the same goals in mind
it's just they have different approaches
about it and then you're even seeing the
gray
with some of the clones here which was
kind of refreshing after being in here
for several episodes of these are clones
who are
following falling in line under order 66
but even there's things that happen that
you can tell they're questioning
what is humane about certain things like
it's just a child
or should we really imprison these
people or kill them
i i was kind of taken aback by how
the clones themselves were actually
starting to go down this path
so thematically what they were doing in
terms of like
something i think this show has been
really strong at doing is the
conversation amongst
the people within war and what is right
and what is wrong
and you know getting lost in politics
and overall objectives but
losing sight of the individualism behind
things
i really appreciate that this show is
going out of its way to do that
and i'll say this too even without
like i wasn't that invested in rebels if
i'm being totally transparent there's
some episodes that i truly
loved and i didn't actually see all of
it
and i've been honest about that before
and see all of rebels
uh but i saw a solid chunk of rebels
um like started a little late
and then i got like the last half of
this show
but the but even with hera
i would say that i was more endeared
towards this thing of like
longing for exploring the galaxy and
taking flight and all that way more than
i
was for like raise wonder
for it you know in like 25 minutes of
this episode you get way more of that
wonder and aspiration and that like hope
beyond the horizon
yeah yeah it was it was a really well
well good it was a really well written
episode with a
with a tense sequence at the end that
because we're just trying to keep things
in order then it's starting to fall
apart and clearly the dad has a specific
alliance in mind
and he's trying to just side with the
galactic empire just to keep things
moving but then by the
by the end once his daughter's in
trouble and realizing that they're being
um uh uh what's the
what's the they have a verdict laid upon
them without actually even going through
trial
you know it's not it's not realizing
okay yeah there's
there's something really messed up about
this yeah you know
and then going in to save the day you
see he's really a badass too
more than just a damn good speaker he
really is a warrior
yeah yeah he he shows that he has you
know the the full-on
grit that his status ought to imply
you know like it seems like he's truly
earned the status he has with the people
yes very true no yeah i thought this
episode was leading the door for you go
for a job
no you're good i didn't want to
interrupt your your flow swinging
yeah no not
did this is available example of an
episode that doesn't feel like it's
necessarily
for kids but it's is still accessible
in a way that you know breathes and
doesn't feel like it's pandering but it
also doesn't feel like it's talking down
you know and so
i really enjoyed yeah it's like halfway
through the episode when the bad bat
ship showed up i was like oh that's
really cool because like you i mean like
i wasn't
even thinking about where they are when
are they going to come into the episode
and i got effortlessly swept up into the
whole yeah the whole situation
uh uh you know of of where the twilights
are in relation to the empire how the
empire is portraying themselves these
doubts they're having of like look
you were supposed to leave this you know
big facility here
uh and not make it a military base you
know so you can already see the cracks
in their agreement and the ways in which
the empire is already starting to assert
their influence nefariously over these
people
and so yeah i thought in 25 minutes they
managed to draw like a really
tense and sort of nuanced you know for
the scale of the show
political situation and then give you
that sort of
star wars hopeful adventure side of like
this kid just wants to get out and see
the galaxy and fly
and whatnot but also probably has her
heart in the right place enough to get
into some good trouble
and then yeah by the time we get into
the middle of the episode and to the
later parts it becomes
very tense and i liked that you know it
didn't feel
out of nowhere whatsoever like even
though the first parts of the episode
aren't like
super dread heavy it feels like a very
natural progression of like this is an
uneasy piece to begin with no matter how
rousing this guy's speech is or whatever
and then seeing the way that the
engagement went down at the end with you
know them sort of playing the chess game
of like no no we're gonna surrender
right now
i'm gonna keep us alive we're gonna
eventually stall
until the reinforcements get here and
even then like they suckered me into
that moment of like
you know when he's got them held up and
uh you know the the
general from the empire is like you know
we're just here to comply you know
yeah all that stuff you know it suckered
me into thinking like okay
at least for the moment we've staved off
the worst and then all of a sudden the
reinforcements landing like damn you
know you feel that sense of loss
and and also the sense of like okay
there's gonna be something up ahead for
hera to do because you know
she's out on her own while her parents
are getting you know imprisoned and
you know who knows what the empire's
gonna do to them then
well i think the political stuff was
managed to be intriguing dialogue
because
it was rooted in a family trouble you
know and then when you make it about
family it makes it personal so it makes
it connective so even if kids are
watching this
you're able to you're you're listening
because you care
because it is a family like when the
parents are talking with tar
you know and you see that the they think
they're
they made a deal for something that's
better but really they're it's becoming
like another militarized planet
and it's not fair it's not fun but then
a lot of the perspective too
comes from the fact of hera and you know
just
going along on these missions and then
asking questions herself
and being intrigued and it and one thing
it seems like the show's doing uh
from from uh uh kanan and and the first
um or just called caleb then but he
eventually becomes kanan
um kanan and rebels in the first episode
and then and then hera here
is that you're you're seeing the the
origins
of learning the truth of what's going on
with this empire that motivates them
into
becoming instrumental in the resistance
um and you know becoming series regulars
of
star wars rebels gotta justify that
why are we spending time on these people
um
yeah and they don't even really do much
to allude to rebels you know like you
would really only know if you've seen
some rebels like oh yeah that character
that character you know
chopper the droid um hera and you know
like being
having her ship ghost and yeah like
having all this is it's cool how i think
it's neat how they're doing it because
they're not doing too many winks at the
camera that are
that would make me feel left out if i
hadn't seen rebels
you know i wouldn't be like i don't feel
attacked by this [ __ ] yeah
i don't feel like this show thinks i'm a
dick for not having seen references
yeah yeah yeah exactly uh it's just more
of an extra treat
in terms of where else it's going so now
i'm like damn we're gonna do this like
all the characters on rebels thing you
know
and and how their journey came to be and
like what
what traumatic memories they have
towards
what made it a personal motivation for
them to
that what made it so strong for them to
fight against the empire
you know that's what it seems like uh it
seems like it was kind of doing
sprinkling in here
throughout it's just a lot of characters
to keep up with you know half the time
i'm like
wait do i i don't reckon i i think i i'm
not gonna say anything
that's me with like so many characters
like i think
i don't i don't remember maybe i'm not
gonna say anything and then i have to
like kind of just slow my brain down and
go
it's not about recognizing people
sometimes just
it's about this sometimes it's more
obvious like oh it's [ __ ] campaign
right there
i reckon yeah of course yeah and
everyone knows campaigner or even caleb
at the kanan at the beginning of
uh the this series like yeah yeah oh of
course um
or hera even but then there's like the
other people like
flip globally or whatever his name is
james yeah
like wait a minute uh i can't really
recall right now yeah
yeah so it's a lot to record about so
you know
bear with um bear with us
but especially bear with john yes
because i'm sitting here always going oh
i think i recognize that guy but i
shouldn't say anything
because i definitely do but i don't want
to make greg feel bad
i know right that's right yeah it's
definitely my motivation
it's also a great little scene between
hera and omega
i thought that was very lovely as well
like this i'm talking about the
they're not not really the force but in
a way the force
yeah yeah they're talking about the
feeling and trusting and it's like
i've heard that conversation about
flight so many times yeah it is about
the feeling
of it letting that guide you that the
technicalities are important though
it's like playing an instrument you need
some theory but also just some
practice and yeah practical just feeling
it
well they always had like those music
cues for when she was
looking upon you know just the
miraculous
idea of flight throughout the galaxies
and the stars they would play like that
john williams score of
you know what the scores they play when
yeah their main characters are looking
up at the sky
the hope and wonder suite yeah yes well
and also
you know like the second they leave the
planet on that mission it's just like
every backdrop is the most
gorgeous sci-fi concept art you've ever
seen of like
three planets cresting the horizon
but the that that exchange of dialogue
um did have me think of a new hope when
luke is
when luke does stop getting all
technical about it but
takes away the the tracking visor thing
and then he just uses his feelings to
trust in the force then something i was
just introduced to like two hours
ricky bobby blindfold that you know yeah
uh yeah so this is a cool one this is a
cool one very cool
quite enjoyed a lot good storytelling
yeah so no less bad batch more
other characters a little more cross
hair
to compensate for not having the bad
badge even though he wasn't even
i feel like the the the one with the
blue shoulder
guard was the most prominent soldier
clone character this episode you know in
all fairness crosshair
always came across evil
i didn't want to say it before but now
he never
came across life like hunter comes
across like
a badass yeah it doesn't come across
evil
crosshairs always come across
[Music]
yeah i don't know there's something
about this quality of voice that even if
you're trying to sound friendly
kind of sounds devious i feel like he's
he's already sort of picked his side you
know like i think
that even if the chip gets removed he's
you know uh
he loves this he's good at this this is
his position in the world now
yeah man he's a merciless bounty hunter
for the galactic empire
oh well that would be way more
heartbreaking i think it'd be powerful
if he gets the chip removed and he still
chooses to be with the bad guys
yeah because i mean that makes a chosen
one
that makes a stronger statement though
it does
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below would you ever do a twilight
kids don't tell your parents you saw
this video
but there's so many think about that
question so many ways to approach it
yeah i bet they have some interesting
tricks
would you would you hold okay all right
you know yeah i know exactly where
you're going with that i'm trying not to
go there
too but you know where we're going
[Laughter]
avatar style a little bit but not
only like one-sided never mind
i should have left it you thought too
much about this
subscribe click bells hit like buttons
tyler hague tyler hague if there's
anybody i would want to come to my
rescue
in an intergalactic fire fight it would
be tyler hague i mean i feel like we've
shouted you out for this show before
we've compared you to wrecker cause
let's face it you would be wrecker
you're so
jolly and yet you could probably crush
me in
one hand if you wanted to but you
wouldn't you know why because you're
your own
man and you're sexy and beautiful and
you know what i don't even care that you
sent greg a ps4 a few years ago
i just care that you're here and you're
supportive
and that your love continues to flow
like the best batch of loving
possible that's why
i licked one so tyler be sexy and
stay stay san diego doing twilight
cover yourself in cheese and do the
twilight dance